[Musique]
salut à tous le médias ce média créé par
la sphère mélenchonistes existe
maintenant depuis cinq mois dès le début
nombre de commentateurs craignait qu'il
ne se transforme en agence de propagande
pour la france insoumise et les prises
de position polémiques n'ont pas tardé
il ya notamment eu claude escale qui a
renvoyé dos à dos al assad et les
insurgés syriens ou encore la désormais
fameuse fake news selon laquelle un
étudiant aurait été dans le coma suite à
l'évacuation de la fac de tolbiac et
d'autres épisodes sont passé plus
inaperçu
par exemple dans la catégorie
manipulation très orienté de
l'information je suis tombé sur une
émission parlons de l'agression du
député france insoumise eric coquerel le
média nous apprend que coquerel aurait
été brutalisé par un membre de l'action
française présentée comme un groupe
royalistes et violent ce qui n'est pas
totalement faux nous expliquant la
dangerosité de cette droite radicale en
faisant appel à un historien mais sans
mentionner un seul instant la nature de
cette agression imagine sauvage or si
vous avez suivi l'actualité
vous savez coquerel s'est juste fait
entarté une méthode très loin donc de
l'ultra violence et qui est aussi
utilisé par l'extrême gauche
mais le plus beau morceau de bravoure
pro france insoumise que j'ai vu faisant
tomber toutes les barrières de la
décence remonte à début mai on est passé
d'un journalisme très orientée à des
méthodes de propagande pure et simple
remettons nous dans le contexte le 5 mai
dernier avait lieu à paris la
manifestation dite la fête à macron
organisé par françois ruffin députée
française ou ghz
l'événement rassemblé quarante mille
manifestants selon la police 5000 selon
les organisateurs et 160 mille selon la
france 1 souligne pour trancher dans la
guerre des chiffres qui se joue après
chaque manifestation depuis quelques
temps un large collectif de médéa s'est
formé pour avoir ses propres estimations
impartiale liée à la société occurrence
qui utilise un comptage électronique
pour dénombrer les manifestants ces
chiffres sont souvent très proches de
ceux de la police pour cette manif
occurrence a compté 38 mille neuf cents
manifestants se chiffrent rend
complètement ridicule ceux avancés par
la france soumise et rufin dans une
séquence qui dure cinq minutes
le média c'est donc est fine et a retiré
absolument toute légitimité à ce
chiffrage de cette séquence je vais vous
présenter quelques moments significatifs
mais je vous invite à la
gardez en entier tout d'abord la
journaliste tente de nous mettre le
doute sur l'intention des protagonistes
et celle de la bastille plus étonnant un
collectif de médias qui se dit
indépendant a fait appel au cabinet
occurrence pour compter les manifestants
et on a dénombré environ 38 mille neuf
cents soit moins que la préfecture de
police alors rémy kenzo tu es là pour
nous parler de ce cabinet occurrence un
peu obscur est ce que tu peux
m'expliquer d'abord ce que c'est plus
étonnant qui se dit indépendant obscures
on multiplie les termes pour mettre en
doute les intentions de ceux qui
remettent en question les chiffres des
insoumis pourtant cette démarche n'a
rien d'étonnante le travail des médias
c'est aussi d'informer sur l'ampleur
d'une mobilisation et ça fait des années
que les journaux cherchent à trancher
dans la guerre des chiffres qui oppose
police et manifestants
avoir recours à une entreprise dont
c'est le métier de compter les
manifestants et donc une démarche
logique on a ensuite eu droit à un
magnifique moment d'hypocrisie huit
mètres du sol
il y à un seul point fixe donc une seule
ligne de comptage au début du trajet ou
été on a couvert trouver de la
manifestation on a quand même vu que
cette manifestation est partie de la
place de l'opéra est allé à république
et ensuite sur la baisse de la bastille
donc il ya des gens imaginent qu ont
juste fait opéra bastille qui sont qui
sont enfin république ou qui sont partis
de la place de la république donc là il
fallait passer devant ce point fixe pour
être comptabilisés sur la toute personne
qui ait franchi la ligne virtuelle
écoutez à ce niveau là bon été rue
réaumur
donc si vous commencez à la place de la
république vous n'étaient pas comptées
comme un manifestant oui voilà
le capteur n'était pas posté en début
mai en milieu de manifestations il
suffit de chercher un peu pour trouver
l'info et puis personnellement pour
avoir fait des dizaines et des dizaines
de l'anif je serais surpris que 50 % des
participants le prix en marche
ensuite il reste encore un ou deux
journalistes à décrédibiliser le dernier
protagoniste le matériel que rémy c'est
vraiment possible de compter des
manifestants qui sont en réalité ça peut
paraître tel très compliqué à vérifier
il ya trop de données à prendre en
compte et ça pose beaucoup de questions
est-ce que l'on compte que les
manifestants qui sont allés jusqu'au
bout du parcours que fait-on de ceux qui
ne sont pas allés jusqu'au point
d'arrivée
est ce qu'il est possible de mettre au
point une méthode scientifique qui soit
totalement fiable pour compte et je ne
sais pas mais personnellement je suis
assez sceptique
en tout cas le mieux pour le savoir
serait d'accéder à toutes les méthodes
en totale transparence de toutes les
tester à plusieurs reprises et donc
plusieurs contextes pour vérifier leur
reproductibilité et les comparer à
l'heure des voitures autonomes et de
l'intelligence artificielle
on sait compter des voyageurs dans une
gare ou des visiteurs dans un salon avec
cette méthode
il n'y a donc pas de raison que ça ne
marche pas dans une rue là on n'est plus
dans l'analyse critique
on est dans le dénigrement total de
l'ennemi la méthode est douteuse et ne
sera jamais au point le cabinet de
conseil obscur et les médias sont soit
disant indépendants tous les éléments de
la chaîne sont discrédités du
commanditaire à l'exécutant en passant
par le pauvre matériel qui n'a rien
demandé aussi peu de neutralité de la
part du média ce n'est plus du
journalisme c'est de la propagande et
pour savoir si la méthode d'occurrence
et fiable comme le suggère le
journaliste il faudrait comparer les
chiffres des différents protagonistes
et contrairement à ce qu'il insinue ils
sont disponibles s'il est vrai qu'il
n'ya pas d'étude comparative global
existantes
il suffit de lire la presse et de les
compiler c'est à dire en gros faire du
journalisme banque est alors que disent
les chiffres globalement ce d'occurrence
sont très proches de ceux de la police
or à chaque fois que des comptages
extérieur neutres ont eu lieu ces
dernières années les chiffres trouvés se
rapprocher de ceux de la police par
exemple lors d'une manifestation contre
la réforme des retraites le doubs
octobre 2010 les syndicats ont compté
trois cent trente mille manifestants
dans le cortège parisien
la police 89 milles une entreprise
espagnole qui utilisaient une méthode
informatique 80000 et mediapart 76000 le
même jour à marseille
des médias ont aussi compté les
manifestants et ont trouvé entre 16800
et 21 mille six cents manifestants quand
la police en comptait 24 1500 et les
syndicats eux 230 milles en septembre
2013 à albi la police a fait appel à un
huissier pour compter les manifestants
résultats l'uci on trouve 4380 la police
4200 et les syndicats vingt mille les
chiffres d'occurrence sont souvent très
proches de ceux de la police qui sont
comme on l'a vu relativement fiable donc
oui cette méthode est efficace plus
comme les méthodes de la police
leurs chiffres sont donc des estimations
fiables avec une marge d'erreur faible à
titre complémentaire voici deux autres
comptage comparatif quoi qu'on en dise
ou quoi qu'on veuille croire ceux qui
ont les chiffres les plus politiques les
plus manipuler ce sont les organisateurs
des manifestations qui ont toujours
intérêt à nous et des chiffres
importants et les polémiques permanentes
sur les chiffres de la police ne sont
que des polémiques politiciennes de la
part de syndicats et partis frustré que
la réalité ne correspondent pas à leurs
attentes et le média en s'inscrivant
dans cette guerre en dos un rôle de
support de relais de caution de la
parole insoumise très loin d'un travail
journalistique même partisan
et au final personnellement je préfère
des journaux détenus par des
milliardaires et proposant une
information partiale mais dont je
connais l'orientation politique et donc
les vielles un journal qui se prétend
indépendant et qui en fait se comporte
comme une agence de propagande en créant
un monde manichéen et c'est sur ces
belles paroles que je vous dis à la
prochaine
[Musique]